tipsy roll seems simple enough that
piece of gooey chocolate wrapped up in a
perfect little bite but believe it or
not these tasty treats save the lives of
US Marines in the Korean War in 1950 at
the North Korean Chosun reservoir US
Marine troops were engaged in battle the
Marines are running out of ammunition
and called for an airdrop of 16
millimeter mortar rounds codename for
these bullets tootsie roll when the
supplies fell from the sky troops were
surprised to find boxes filled with the
actual candies where the bullets this
fluke turned out to be a blessing in
disguise freezing cold temperatures had
cracked vehicle fuel lines leaving
troops stranded and although the candies
were frozen they softened easily in the
mouths of servicemen so good Marines
quickly realized they can melt the
candies down to a putty and seal the
broken pipes good as new
when the chocolate reef rose they were
able to drive to safety in their newly
functional vehicles the Marines to
successfully escape the reservoir admit
that tootsie rolls had a big hand in
their survival and they call themselves
the chosen few I'd call that a pretty
sweet victory
you
you